ils voudraient fuir mais ils n'osent
même pas à marioupol ville stratégique
maintes fois bombardée encerclée par les
forces russes la population se sent
abandonné
on a plus d'électricité
on n'a plus rien à manger en a plus de
médicaments on n'a plus rien
[Musique]
les policiers ukrainiens les décourage
d'emprunter le couloir humanitaire mise
en place par la russie
toutes les routes pour sortir de la
ville ont été minées malheureusement
c'est plus sécurisé pour nous tous de
rester à l'intérieur de la ville en sous
sol que dans des abris
officiellement à marioupol comme dans
quatre autres villes et agglomérations
la russie a instauré des cessez-le-feu
locaux et l'ouverture de corridors
humanitaires
mais le gouvernement ukrainien les
accusent de ne pas respecter leurs
engagements
rien qu à marioupol 400000 crâniens sont
prises en otage ils sont constamment
garder
ils ont failli soeur russe à sentir sur
les couloirs humanitaires par lequel les
civils tentent de fuir
plus au nord a soumis ces images la
teste des vivres sont parvenus jusqu'à
la ville et des dizaines de civils ont
pu être évacués en bus notamment les
étudiants étrangers
regardez s'il reste des places
peut-être enfin pour la fin du cauchemar
mais difficile de savoir combien de
temps les sélections vraiment tenu
un habitant de ce meeting ce matin de sa
fenêtre
les combats sont tout près
même constat à l'ouest de kiev à irin
ils sont des milliers à avoir quitter
leurs abris pour fuir au plus vite
pendant la trêve
isolement des bruits sourds des tirs
d'artillerie selon les spécialistes les
annonces de couloirs humanitaires sont
une tactique militaire déjà utilisé par
la russie en tchétchénie plus anciennes
il s'agit de dire à ceux qui veulent
partir vous pouvez partir mais c'est un
maintenant deux chez nous en tout cas
vers nous ligne parce que sinon vous
serez considéré comme des ennemis et il
vous arrivera ce qui devra vous arrivés
depuis le début de la guerre selon l'onu
au moins 400 civils ont été tuées et 800
blessés